قيل ان الاسواق قادم وفعلا مسلسل التسريح
لم يتوقف منذ 2022 والحقيقه ان الرقم الذي
ذكرته مراسلتنا وصل الى 65,000 تقريبا في
شهر فقط رقم هنقيسيا اذا ما قربناه
بعمليات التسريح في عام 2022 التي وصلت
الى 155,000 تقريبا نتحدث عن 2100 شخص
يفقدون وظائفهم في قطاع التكنولوجيا كل
يوم مجزره والسبب برايك كبار الرؤساء
تنفيذيين كما مايكروسوفت مثلا ان القطاع
يشهد تنافسيه حاده لا ترحم وتدفعوا الى
تخصيص المواهب ورؤوس الاموال في مجال
النمو طويل الامل هذا جزء من الحقيقه
والجزء الاخر الذي لم يعترف به المسؤول ان
ما حدث كان نتيجه السلسله من القرارات
الاداريه المتعوره ومنها حمى التوظيف في
2019 و201220 ارتفعت نسبه التوظيفته قطاع
بطريقه الهستريه وبنحو 100% او اكثر
بالنسبه لامازون وميتا وسناب شات وفي مصر
وسلف فورس وتويتر ومايكروسوفت زاد توضيه
بمتوسط 60% هذه الشهيه في التوظيف جاءت
نتيجه طفره الارباح التي حققتها الشركات
والقطاع في ايام الاغلاق الاولى عندما
انصب الاستهلاك العالميه على الاجهزه
الالكترونيه والخدمات التي تقدمها شركات
التكنولوجيا لدعم الشركات الكبيره
والناشئه زياده الطلب على الخدمات الدفع
عمالقه التكنولوجيا للنفاعي نحو استثمار
وتطوير المشاريع لكن الواقعه عاد الي يمحي
الاحلى الافتراضيه بكبسه زر جاءت من روسيا